Daniel Friedman: Hello and welcome. It's January 24,
2023. We're in ActInf Livestream number
1.7 on governing continuous
transformation. Off to you, Bleu.
Bleu Knight: Great. So we are the Active Inference
Institute, a participatory online
institute that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied Active
Inference Lab. You can reach us at all
of these social media links. This is a
recorded and archived live stream, so
please provide us with feedback so that
we can improve upon our work. All
backgrounds and perspectives are welcome
here and we will be following good video
etiquette for live streams. Again, if
you'd like to participate. Active
Inference is our main website and
there's a link to get involved and join
many of the ongoing collaborative
projects or live streams or both.
This is, as Daniel said, Bookstream 1.7.
So it's our 7th contextualization video
on this book governing Continuous
Transformation by Bijan Khezri. So we
will just jump right into it.
I am Bleu. I'm an independent researcher
in New Mexico and I will pass it
off to Daniel. All right, I'm Daniel.
I'm a researcher in California and just
happy to see this series continue. Tyler.
I'm Tyler, I'm a protocol designer
and researcher in California.
Great. So we are in
part two free energy governance of this
textbook. And the name of this chapter
is Cognition from Superposition to
Reality. And so I think that that kind
of hints to some quantum stuff that
might be elaborated more towards the end
of this chapter and in the next chapter.
And just a few keywords for this
chapter, but still quite a bit of
content here. So Tyler, do you want to
read the start of the abstract? Do you
mind? Sounds good. Can you guys hear me
okay, by the way? Great. All right.
Attention based view and enacted this
approach address FPG's cognition
dimension to this DAG strategy.
Management research is not entirely deep
change from its very path dependency of
putting perception ahead of the action,
ie. Putting environment ahead of
strategy. While ABV's structure
cognition nexus is FEG's critical
building block, ABV erroneously treats
action as a consequence of perception.
Once we embrace attention as action
generated, we start understanding that
clever analysis and form of belief
updating follows action generated
stimuli, not the other way around. ABV
is trapped in the old school limitations
imposed by bounded rationality and the
discontinuous and distributed quantum
world agents. Bounded rationality is
meaningless as enacted inference
empowers the world to deliver a
supervisory signal, effectively agents
offload the burden of cognition to the
environment. Bounded rationality is
replaced by extended cognition. That
battedness of human cognition is
effectively neutralized. Bleu would even
take that one.
Sure, there are at least as many reality
models as there are economic actors.
Every organization chooses akin to
holding acting upon a light torch in the
awareness which environmental
significance to attend to. Whatever the
torch highlights is equivalent to
breaking a quantum wave of probabilities
moving from superposition to reality
intermediated by the Markov blanket
environment enactment is essentially a
purpose directed, interactive,
inferential and social learning sense
making process. All right, so there
are two sections to this chapter. The
first is attention based view, and the
second is an activist approach. So,
Tyler, do you want to take this slide?
Sure. All right, so attention based
view. So we actually touched on this a
couple of streams ago in the context of
when we introduced this, was that Bijan
was going through different models of
thinking about firm cognition, and
they're all limited in their own sense,
including attention based view. And
we'll go deeper into why attention based
view is limited, but also chaos
important ways of thinking about how
firm cognition works. And so the general
idea of it is that attention is a
limited resource and that permeates
through all levels of the hierarchy of
an organization. So on the individual
level, you have limited attention that
bounds that bounds cognition of
what you're able to understand and
perceive and decisions you're able to
make. And the boundedness of your
individual cognition bubbles up into a
social context, which bubbles the kind
of decisions a group of people can make,
and then that finally bubbles up into
your organizational cognition, which
manifests through different rules,
positions, players, and resources.
So this is just to say, like, hey, we
only have so many things that we can
spend our time and energy on and that
manifests at larger levels in the kinds
of rules that we make within an
organization. Bleu Daniel, anything you
would add here?
No. So I can read this claim. While
attention based views structure
cognition, nexus is a critical building
block of free energy governance,
fundamentally, attention to base views
suffers from severe shortcomings that
weaken its relevance to practice. By
highlighting some of attention based
views most fundamental weaknesses, we
should further cement the case for free
energy governance as a meta theory
connecting in circular causality,
structure, cognition, and capabilities.
Once we understand how the Bayesian
brain is building a model of its world,
we start seeing how anachronistic and
full of friction our deep rooted
conceptions of organizational attention
are. Do you guys have
anything to add here? Okay,
cool. All right. So bounded rationality.
So this was a concept that Bijan brought
up here in this chapter, and it was
introduction by Herbert Simon, the term
in like, 1957. And I pulled this from
the Stanford Encyclopedia of Philosophy.
So his introduction of this term was a
shorthand for his position against
neoclassical economics and his call to
replace the perfect rationality
assumptions of homo economicus with the
conception of rationality tailored to
cognitively limited agent. And so this
little figure here shows
the cognitive limitations and imperfect
information and time constraints that
we're faced with when we have to make a
decision. So we always are limited by
what we can hold in our brain and the
view of the information that we have.
And we were talking about complexity
like computing pi. Like, we could get a
more accuracy numerical digit of pi,
but we're limited by time. Like, if we
go on and on and on, we could get more
and more accurate. But, like, why is
3.14 good enough? Because I can pull it
up in, like, a split second from memory.
And so all of this configures our
bounded rationality, and we use a
process that Herbert Simon introduced as
satisficing to make a suboptimal
decision or our best possible decision
with the bounded rationality that we're
faced with. And a quote
from the Herbert Simon says, broadly
stated, the task is to replace the
Global rationality of economic man with
the kind of rational behavior that is
compatible with the access to
information and the computational
capacities that are actually possessed
by organisms, including man, in the kind
of environments in which such organisms
exist. Tyler, do you want to read where
this bounded rationality concept is
introduced in the computer? Sure. Yeah.
I think the context here is that he's
trying to connect ABV to
boundarrationality by saying, all right,
well, you have limited attention. How
does a firm decide where his attention
is spent? How do you make that decision
collectively? So he says, in ABV top
leadership's, attention to the right
issues and solutions considered the
source, the firm's competitive advantage
essentially is content rather than
process centric. And the firm's
performance, Bobble Neck, remains upper
echelon's attention, ie. Boundary
rationality. The critical question then
is how in the first place, context is
selected to determine the tension or
have bottom up market signals connected
with top down, upper echelon
expectations and predictions to
determine tension. And so we're saying,
like, ABV doesn't really explain how
that attention gets directed in the
first place. ABV is trapped in the old
school limitations of hostile outbounded
rationality and discontinuous and
distributed quantum world agents.
Bounded rationality is meaningless as
perceptual content is given in our
predictions, and this is precisely what
allows the world to deliver the
supervisory signal. Effectively, the
firm is offloading the burden of
cognition to its environment. So
boundary rationality is replaced by
extended cognition. The boundedness of
human cognition is effectively
neutralized. Bleu, Daniel,
anything to add? There we'll
go to the next slide where Bleu can
explain more about extended cognition.
Cool. So, extended cognition, I took
this from this article by Mark Sprivac.
Extended cognition takes the idea that
your mind is on your smartphone,
literally. So it says that human
cognitive states and processes sometimes
spill outside of our heads into objects
in our environment. And this is
something that we've looked at and
talked about before in many ways. Like,
even with Avalon, I'm not sure if you
guys talked about it yesterday on the
stream, but in the thinking like a state
Livestream that we did, we talked quite
a bit about extended cognition and
cumulative cultural evolution and how a
lot of our cognition is out there
embedded in our environment. So that we
don't have to think about it. When I
grew up, there was no Internet, so we
would have to like colton like, my son
in the car the other day asked me some
question, and I was like, you're going
to have to ask Alexa or Google. And he
was like, will you ask your phone for
me? And it was like some fact question,
like, how many bones are in the body or
something that I couldn't remember off
the top of my head. And I said, well,
wait till we get to school. And then
I'll ask my phone, because my phone was
like, whatever, playing music or doing
something, and I'm driving, right? And
he was like, that was so long. You can't
wait 15 minutes to get to school to
answer the question. I was like, man,
when I was a kid, if I wanted to know
the answer to this question, I would
have to go to the library, look in the
card Cadillac, find a book, like, or
encyclopedia or something. Oh, it's the
goodest book of world record. That's
what it was. It was like the world's
smallest pancake or something like that.
And so we would have to find the book
and then look it up in the book. And it
would take days, like, if we could even
remember the question for that long.
And he was like, oh, my God, where would
you live? This kind of extended
cognitive niche, we could just know
everything with a click of a few buttons
is amazing. Do you guys have anything to
add here? Extended cognition. Sorry, I
rambled.
All right, then maybe Tyler wants to
talk about channeling attention. Cool.
So, yeah, your extended cognition is not
just you as this single known
organization, and it actually
encompasses both your environment, the
firm around it, and also maybe the
environment around the firm. Like, how
does the attention of that cognition get
channeled out? How do you decide what
matters, what doesn't matter? And so
what Bijan says is while ABV views
organizations as systems of structurally
distribute attention, where structure
channel attention, ABV treats the
process of channeling as a black box.
So it's like a framework for thinking
about how cognition is limited in
organizational context, but it doesn't
really tell you what's going on. For
that reason, it doesn't end up being
super practical, at least in pajamas.
To it goes on to say, neither UEV nor
ABV, both fundamentally top down
oriented frameworks, have given due
consideration to the dynamic interplay
between top management team TMT and the
board directors. More specifically,
there's no transparent structural link
between the upper echelon level and
field intelligence, for example. The
very process that governs the two
layers, interaction determining affirmed
attention and the actions remains
opaque. And so I think broadly what
beyond saying is that especially like
Beni and activist approach of thinking,
that how your actions in the environment
determine your perception, that's
missing an ABV. And that's a critical
aspect of understanding how cognition
happens in an organization. But
specifically the interplay between the
board and the management team,
which is in previous triumph. He spent a
lot of time describing why that's a
really critical and important
relationship for firm cognition.
Bleu Dale, anything you do that on here.
I would just add that or maybe emphasize
the point that we talk about a lot about
top management here and the board and
that interaction and then the
interactions between different levels of
the hierarchy, like from the top all the
way to the bottom. And I think that we
emphasize the importance of the feeding
forward and feeding back and the
interaction between the layers and how
information is transmitted between them.
But there's no real concrete
examples of how to best do that.
And I think that this is like for me,
not just in a firm but also in the
body. How is that information
transmitted? How does my big toe
prioritize what goes to my brain?
Obviously, if I kick something really
hard and hurt my toe or if I get like a
hangnail or like and agreement toenail
or something, it really hurts. But
otherwise my toe, I don't even know it's
ever talking to my brain. So it has to
provide salience somehow and how this is
done. And I don't know that's so
critical for me. I think that that's
really at the heart of all of active
inference lab, hierarchical structuring
stuff.
All right,
attention coherence here.
Bijan quotes Ocasio and this is like
a 2011 paper,
I guess, or maybe book, but he puts a
lot of emphasis on Ocasio as one of the
people that his work really rests
strongly upon. So I encourage you to
read the chapter if you want to learn
more or go straight to Ocasio itself.
So he says the introduction of top down
and bottom up attentional processes is
also implicit in the WIC and Succliffe
concept of the quality of organizational
attention and in the rerop analysis of
attentional triangulation combining
attentional stability, top down,
attentional vividness, bottom up, and
attentional coherence combining both.
And he goes on to say that attention
based view cannot explain attentional
coherence. And so getting at what I just
was saying about the interaction between
the top down and bottom up and how that
works can be explained in attention
based view. Maybe it can be explained in
free energy governance, or we can maybe
get some guidance on how to best do
that. Hopefully in the coming chapters
we'll learn more. Do you guys have any
comments here?
Do you want to read these claims for me?
Tyler sure. So ABV erroneously
treats action as a consequence of
attention and perception. According to
PPF prediction processing framework,
action is determined in circular
causality to stimulate that they pay
attention and sense making. While ABV is
laying a critical foundation in looking
cognition structure, the question arises
whether ABV's attention will need to be
redefined as something more granular and
practical. So tension not only is too
diffused the cognitive concept but also
is hard to meaningfully operationalize
in the context of continuous strategic
renewal. So exactly what Bleu was saying
on the previous slide ABV explains like
okay, I understand why attention being
limited shapes the firm's cognition but
what do I even do with that information?
How is that going to be impactful? How
can I model that? And the John is
cleaning like well it's not that useful
right now but he's teasing that maybe it
could be with active inference or free
energy governance. Yeah what
is that something more granular and
practical? How do we focus attention?
How do we break attention up into sub
components that are more granular and
practical? What is in our field of
view or what should be in our field of
view like what we're looking ant what
we're prioritizing and do those things
line up? I don't know, I could speculate
all day but it's hard to know really
what that more granular and practical
thing might be. One other
quick note on that is there's the
question of coherence and adaptivity.
For example, that student answering
their cell phone in the classroom on the
previous cartoon that may have certain
dimensions of adaptivity or fulfill
certain preferences of one agent but not
another. And then there's this question
of action orientation. And so if we're
always in the business of asking about
the environment, doing the market
research, not thinking about the
strategy, taking this sort of perception
first mindset, there still is the
question of attentional coherence. Are
we paying attention and sense making,
putting all the pieces together from
what we're perceiving? And also there
is this inactive shift which is
incomplete, but it's part of the puzzle
which is we want to be having attention,
regimes of attention on our action.
And that brings together the embodiments
and the inactive view. With the
attentional view, which, as brought up,
doesn't really describe what attention
is and still can be mobilized in a
passive setting. But together we have
this active attention and that Flowers
active inference where attention is
internal action.
So isn't it like pay attention to what
you're paying attention to? Is that like
a nested little hint there?
Well in live stream 28 we saw a three
layer model of attention and
there is no single one way to model any
cognitive phenomena. It's going to be up
to people in different settings to
understand what treatments of attention
are insightful or useful or applicable.
I don't know, I think that paying
attention to what you're paying
attention to kind of gets a
lot of attention in the business context
or even in prioritizing your to do
lists, right? Are you just like fighting
fires all the time or are you making
progress to do things going forward?
Making progress on your own goals? So I
think I don't know, that might be a
critical governing variable.
Let me read this claim in that regard.
Predictive processing framework in the
form of active inference is potentially
a critical complement to and possibly
substitute for the attention base view.
Predictive processing framework provides
the concepts and logics that give new
meaning to the linkage of structure and
cognition according to predictive
processing framework. Prediction Models
and Predictions self optimized as a
matter of pursuing surprise minimization
by way of free energy minimization it is
strictly a priori, not an attention
challenge, but a purpose directed
prediction challenge. The evolution of
self driving vehicles provides an
exemplary illustration of this point.
Once the challenge was conceived as a
prediction rather than attention
challenge, the road to perfection is
simply a matter of continuous and
purpose directed prediction error
minimization. And I don't know what is
really meant by this. The challenge of
self driving was conceived as a
prediction once people predicted that it
would happen. I'm not really sure what
means here. I could maybe take a stab at
that one because I think what he's
saying is that for a self driving car
that's the kind of thing that if you
were being using purely linear thinking,
only using the things you know already
about the world, a self driving car
wouldn't be like an obvious next step.
You have to take this leap of faith and
action oriented leap of faith just
saying no, we're going to build a self
driving car and then once you've decided
that that's your path, you're going to
go down. Now it's just like optimization
on that path. And so I think he was
illustrating the inactivist approach of
like hey, a self driving vehicle.
There's nothing obvious or self evident
about that needing to happen. But once
you decide it's going to happen, then
it's a prediction problem.
Agree there's different readings one
way also not knowing this selfdriving
car game.
If we were in this passive perception
first world, then there would be
the main issue to resolve would be
understand from noisy sensor readings
where is the location of a person and
producer uncertainty about where the
person is or what that object is.
However, once we see it in terms of this
continuous purpose directed
predictionary minimization, we're going
to center the role of action, gas break
and turning and a few other affordances
that cars have. So instead of going for
all the decimal points on whether that's
a person or a mailbox or a cone,
what does it look like to take this
unfolding action oriented view where
you're aligning with your preferences?
For example, not to cause harm to people
and then lesser priority not to cause
harm to objects. Maybe steering away
from that object. You can have a good
policy posterior on it's, a good and
likely action without having all the
decimals of precision about the
environment. So once we understand how
essential action is to the self driving
car, it reframes what we have to do with
the sensor data and it centralizes
the relevance of the strategy.
Yeah, I do remember something about some
change in self driving in the sensor
system. So maybe that references the
attention versus prediction problem or
maybe that's being referred to
internally in there. Not sure.
Okay, so that sums up the attention
based view section. And we're moving in
now to the enactivism approach.
So this is at the start of the chapter.
The Dean quotes Thompson 2007 and
says the organism's environment is the
sense it makes of the world. The
environment is a place of significance
and valence as a result of the Global
action of the organism. So again,
taking this like action centric
perspective and he quotes Ramstead at
Alice 2020 by saying active coherence is
an active inference. And he says,
indeed, the essential question is how
the firm brings forth significance and
valence that does not preexist, but is
the result of action centric and
socially constructed engagement with the
outer world equivalent to internally
assigning probabilities to the external
hidden unknown states in the form of a
Markov blanket? This revealing of
significance and valence then lays the
foundation for generating shared meaning
and shared expectations in the form of
unique interpretation models, belief
systems underlying firm performance and
survival.
We can go on to see what else he says.
So he makes the claim. Daft and Week
1984 differentiate between environment
driven and interpretation driven
approaches to strategy making. And in
this big quote, they say in environment
driven frames, top managers experience
environments as concrete, hard,
measurable and determinant on the other.
And top managers of firms confronting
more unstable or unanalyzable
environments are thought to construct,
coerce or enact a reasonable
interpretation that makes previous
actions sensible. Thus they attempt to
construct their environments through
their strategies, rather than developing
strategies in response to environments,
resulting in strategy, environment
beliefs or proactive logics. And he also
says, despite Wick's strong influence on
strategic management research, to this
day, the environment driven approach
remains dominant. So I think that this
is like one of the central themes that's
emerging in the book is that
the environment is somewhere out there.
It's some very real thing. It's taken to
be like, it is this way, it's always
going to be this way.
And kind of something that Daniel and I
have talked about at length, like the
niche as responding to the organism.
The niche responds to the organism just
as much as the organism responds to the
niche. And whether or not the niche
includes other organisms in the
environment or not is kind of irrelevant
when we have things like books and
smartphones. So this environment is
changing and it's changing maybe so fast
and so much that this environment driven
framework is perhaps not effective.
So unstable or unanalyzable environments
is maybe like this discontinuous
environment that Bijan speaks of,
because the environment is changing
fast, like maybe faster than it's ever
changed before, because of our Global
connectivity and many other reasons. So
now maybe all environments are unstable
or unanalyzable or more unpredictable
than they've been before. So that this
constant update or attempt to attempting
to construct the niche rather than
viewing it as something stable is maybe
more important for firm persistence. Do
you guys have any comments here? Yeah,
I just think on the second half of that
of very unstable and uninsurable
environments that really resonates in a
startup context where a lot of times
startup fanners will have no pretense of
knowing anything that's going on in the
environment. They're very
clear about their ignorance of the
world. Instead they run small
experiments to kind of gauge what's
going on in the external world and then
kind of construct the worldview from
there. Rather than saying hey, we have
this great business idea, let's scale
this thing. It's more like hey, let's
discover who our users are. Which I
think really corresponds
well with that second half the quarter.
Also with our classical temperature
examples. Let's just say that we were in
a house and there was a heating element.
If we think that over the timescale of
days things agent going to change that
much, we might look towards a strategy
of turning on and off the heater. So
dealing with the environment variability
in the niche we're in. Whereas if we're
in an open space so there's no point in
having any strategy of trying to heat
the local air because it's just going to
get blown away in the next second. Then
you might center decision making around
finding a warmer location. And so when
there's a more stable environment then
it puts us into a mode of like
understanding the variability patterns,
the circadian patterns and temperature
and responding with what we have or
maybe inventing something new to respond
to those regularities. But when there's
the discontinuous and complex
environmental settings that this work is
focused on, it centers this kind of
creating one's own niche through action,
not just modifying it more locally to do
the best one can.
Cool. Tyler, do you want to read this
claim? Do you mind? Sure. So every
organization chooses kind holding a
light porch in the darkness which
environmental significance to act upon
and to attend to, whatever the torch
highlights is equivalent to breaking a
quantum wave of probabilities, moving
from superposition to reality,
intermediated by the markup blanket. In
this regard, strategy research is
challenged to be less mechanistically
determined environment to strategy, but
more quantum strategy to environment.
The quantum world is more tenuous than
the one imagined. And this is actually a
quote from Cerritelli. This is not Sean.
The quantum world is more tenuous than
the one imagined by old physics. It is
made up of happenings get discontinuous
events without permanence. There's a
world of fine texture, intricate and
fragile as Venetian lace. Every
interaction is an event and it is these
light and ephemeral events that weave
reality not the heavy objects charged
with absolute properties and our
philosophy positive in support of these
events.
Cool, thanks. So Bijan
goes on to say and I think we'll come
back to this quantum because I have some
questions here. So we'll come back to
this at the closer to the end of this
section, but right now let's read this
claim. Bijan says the critical
consideration is how an organism sorry,
too much biology. How an organization
transmorphs the sensing and sense making
activity at the individual level.
Hinton a firm's institutionalized
environmental enactment as a basis for
continuum strategic renewal. Enactment
is essentially an interactive and
generative social learning sensemaking
process, hence active inference. Dong et
al. Elegantly addressed this micro macro
dichotomy. They say, While hypothesis
setting is an individual activity,
hypothesis testing is an organizational
activity. According to Smirchich and
Stubborn, organization members actively
form enact their environments through
social interaction. A pattern of
enactment establishes the foundation of
organizational reality and in turn has
effects in shaping future enactments.
The task of strategic management, in
this view is organization making to
create and maintain systems of shared
meaning that facilitate organized
action. Do you guys have any comments
here? One thought
I'm imagining a fleet of boats,
the upper etchelon. View and the board
of directors specifically. They may not
need to be concerned with the minutiae
of move the wheel left, move the wheel
right on this boat at that time,
but they are, as it says here,
the task of strategic management in this
view is organization making. So that
justifies some of this upper etchelon.
Focus. It's not coming, I don't think,
from a place of elitism or chauvinism
about those upper management groups,
but it's especially targeting to those
who are in a cognition to be involved in
organization making, which isn't
steering the boat. But allowing the
agency and enactment to happen in the
front line requires those not
in the front line to take the view that
is being promoted here rather
than just imagine if we had enough
sensors on enough boats. We could have
all of them viewed up in front of us.
And then we could call out who should
turn left and who should turn right.
With the three to eight board meetings
per year, it's not going to happen. So
what is the organization making that
responds to that look like?
I'm kind of curious about what you just
said because something I've been
wondering about through this whole book
is whether a board is really necessary
for that meeting making or whether that
can be done in a more distributed way.
And I think Dean touched on this a
little bit in our last call with him
saying that, well, this is their job.
The board's job specifically is to be
able to distinctions from the
conversation. So they're in this unique
position to really build meaning and
create sense making and dislocate that
process. But I'm wondering if it's
actually necessary for. That to happen
because it does strike me as a very top
down. Like, imposing a sensemaking
framework on an organization is a ton of
power and it does very much constrain
the cognitive abilities of the larger
organization. And it strikes
me just on this simple reading of it
that maybe something is missing from
that or maybe a potential other way
forward that is less top down is
possible. But I'm probably
misunderstanding the John as well. So
I'm curious what you all think. It'll be
so fun to explore, but let's
just say that the task of strategic
management is organization making.
Maybe this is a saddle point view
that everybody can get on board with,
but then we go great upper management's
role and function was organization
making and now everyone has access to
the tools and at least view or comment
access to the process of organization
making. So trans
morphing the understanding of what the
upper, etchelon. Does in terms of
organization making. So just double
checking, you're not involved in
steering the ship, you're involved in
organization making and action
orientation. And then
perhaps that function could be taken
on by another organizational
structure with that as
its focus or that could be an emergent
functionality of other organizational
units. But it's really hard to go from
vision coming from the top to simply a
vision that's coherent arising from the
bottom and from the outside. And so
there's an intermediate view that
qualifies the conversation differently.
Yeah, I think that makes sense. I think
we have observed that sense making
happening both in the bottom and the
top, and especially in tech companies
where you will have a board and they are
making top down decisions. But you will
also have consultants almost embedded at
each level of the hierarchy who do that
sense making at every level of the
hierarchy and bubble that up also to the
top. So I think it does exist where you
kind of have it's not purely sensemaking
happening at the board or TMT level.
So I just want to point out the first
sentence here and it really resonates
with what you just said, Tyler. Like the
way that I've been reading this, he says
the critical consideration is how an
organization transmorphs the sensing and
sense making activity, ant the
individual level into a firm
institutionalized environment enactment
as a basis for continuous strategic
renewal. Like what? I took that
individual level as the very bottom up
thing because it's like each little
worker ant right in the colony. I took
that as like a very bottom up and
distributed thing. Like how do you take
that and turn it into some kind of
collective sense making? But really that
could also be like there's an individual
level at the top. Like each board of
directors is selected for their
different expertise, right? So like you
have a variety, I mean, ideally you have
a variety of different views and
perspectives at the board level and then
how do those individuals translate their
sensemaking into something that the
institution can then act upon? So I
think that is a very rings very true
that this individual sensing and sense
making is happening at the top and at
the bottom. I think that rings true.
I just want to draw one distinction
based on some experience of doing the
top down sense making. So I was a
strategy consultant for a while, and a
lot of times you would do the top down
sense making where you would talk to all
levels of the hierarchy and you kind of
act as the board. In that situation and
kind of bubble up all of this
information into a top level idea
about what's happening in the
organization, what the narrative is and
what actions they should take. So it's
like very top down structured, but
there's like other models of doing this
where each node in the organization is
more or less operating independently and
sense making it dependently, whereas the
top down structure isn't as important.
And maybe you're saying the same thing,
but it Atreides me as like a little bit
different, where sense making isn't
happening through a bubble up process,
through a pyramid, but rather happening
in like a web in a mesh. And that
strikes me as like an important
difference. But maybe Bijan is saying
the same thing. I'm not sure.
It's hard to know. And it's hard to also
know how when you
have like even at a single layer of the
hierarchy, like you have 25 people and
twelve of them think one thing and 13 of
them think another thing. How do you
make sense of that where there's this
like opposing viewpoint? How do you
collectively get buy in to proceed with
either strategy A or strategy B even at
a single level and then pass that
information up or down without like,
well, I wanted it to be this way or I
wanted the people going like the
opposing view, like whatever wins,
right? Like in a vote the 13 would win
if that's the way that it's run or maybe
there's weighted voting or who knows,
however a firm would structure itself.
But it's really important, I think,
to get strategy buy in from everyone,
at least hear all of the points in order
to proceed and have
the viewpoint adopted widely and get
people to get behind it. So I don't
know, it's a hard, weird thing to think
about how that information is passed up
or down in the hierarchy.
All right, Tyler, do you have something
to add? Well, I was just going to add
that this is a really important point.
I'm not just trying to be like pedantic
about it. Actually, a lot of
organizational strategy debates hinge on
this of whether really you can do sense
making in a hierarchical way. It's
really like a pyramid or like a more
mesh network. So the mesh networks are
more like teal organizations or
hilocracies. And this is a very
contentious point, and I was hoping that
we could figure it out head on or
understand the genre's perspective on
it. And I think he thinks both are
possible because I think he's hinted at
that in the previous live streams, but
he hasn't said it super clearly so far.
But something I've been very eagerly
waiting for him to spell out clearly.
So maybe he'll get to it in the next
chapters. So, Tyler, I have a request.
Like, in the next Livestream, you have
to put in like a slide on Holocaust and
explain that to us in a very, like,
break it all down, break down all these
different strategies for us because you
have that expertise and I'm lost. So
there's my special request. Okay,
awesome. I've just been in lots of
debates, even within especially in Dows,
where they try to do the mesh network
version of things, not the pyramid, and
a lot of times just like a total
disaster and it doesn't work. But
there's always this dream, especially in
Dazzling, oh, could this be possible?
Do you actually need the hierarchy at
all? Can this work more like a spider
web rather than the pyramid?
And this whole book, I've been waiting
for the answer to that. So I'm excited
to ask the Dean. Yeah,
and also just getting these dimensions
sketched, because what if it's like,
well, yeah, we can have a slime mold,
but then we may split a lot and not all
the things that split off may survive.
If that is tolerable or preferable to
you. Slime mold it is. But if we all
want to ride or die together, then this
kind of a structure is what we want. So
making sure that there's like, consent
and transparency around what people are
wanting to be in, because also in sort
of emergent online 2020s eras teams and
Dows, it's like, are we hanging out in
the group chat? Are we building a
product that's going to change the
information environment? Are we learning
about other projects? Are we learning
about other early projects to invest in?
It can move very rapidly amongst those
spaces, and at the risk of trying
to capture four birds and getting none,
there's all these other failure modes.
But maybe, again, that's what those
people wanted to do in that blanket at
that time. But when you have
shareholders and a board and there are
some responsibilities that come into
play and these sort of okay to fail or
okay to sunset experiments in online
organization hopefully can reveal
empirical patterns that we use to
carry forward organizational technique.
Yeah. My read so far on what Dean is
doing is that he's saying, like, yes,
sure, a slide mold organization is a
thing you could conceive of, and that's
a valid way of thinking about an
organization. But he's specifically
thinking about the legal context that a
lot of organizations live in. Today and
making active coherence or free energy
governance work for those organizations
the world that we live in. So I'm not
sure if that resonates with you guys.
Okay, nice debate.
Tangential. I don't know. Information
dive. All right, so Bijan
makes this point and he says
organizations are challenged to better
distinguish how their actions differ
from those of others as they construct
eco niches. And he really kind of
gives this like, a lot of
background information. But I just
pulled these two quotes about
distinguishing self from other, like how
do you distinguish what is me and what
is you? And also about how do you sense
make like, help others see what's in
your head in talking about these things?
He gives two examples which I thought
were really cool from biology, so I
wanted to read them. He quotes Godfrey
Smith 2016 and says, whenever a fish
emits a pulse, it also sends a copy of
the command around to the sensing
system, enabling that system to
counteract the effect of the pulse it
has produced. The fish is tracking and
registering the distinction between self
and other, between the effects on its
senses of its own actions and the
effects of events going on around it.
And then he also goes on to say, to use
the example of sharks, he says sharks.
He quotes Lanza at Align 2020 Paper. He
says sharks have organs called Lorenzini
Blisters, which sense electrical Fields.
Dolphins and tooth whales, for example,
benefit from echolocation abilities
whose sound pulses can penetrate soft
tissue to provide them with an Xray like
mental image of the objects of interest.
In order to tell the other dolphins what
they have discovered, they actually
create a visual picture of what they
just saw in the minds of other dolphins.
So I didn't put a full explanation of
echolocation because it gets
complicated. But here's this dolphin and
it sends out these exploration rays.
And if something is in its echolocation
site, because it's not really site,
right? But if something sees it, then
the arrays that are reflected back are
molded around. So you can imagine
ripples through water. So they mold
around like a rock or a stream. And so
what comes back is actually like a
physical ripple picture of the rock
or whatever it's seeing. And so it can
actually then modify its own
echolocation sounds to give a picture of
the rock to someone else, which I think
is so cool, right? Like to a dolphin
friend, not like someone else, because I
couldn't see a ripple picture of a rock,
but maybe its dolphin friends could.
Anyway, I think that that is a neat idea
of how we always ask people like,
do you Andersen me? Do you know what I
mean? Do you really know? But it's
really hard to know perceptually what
someone else is, what's behind their
markup blanket, right? Do you guys have
anything to add here? Sorry, I'm just
the one fascinated with biological
sensing and sense making.
Okay, tyler, do you want to read this
claim for us? Sure. So, more
specifically, optimization is essential
across the constituent elements
determining the circular causality
underlying active coherence lab. One,
actions generating reliable sensory
input precision. Two, the ability to
express beliefs about beliefs
consequences. Sophistication, to enact
only a bounded set of external states.
Three, leveraging salience without
missing the very air signaling value
that non salient signaling may
nonetheless behold. And four, force that
to anticipatory, develop and strengthen
the internal states, ie. Firm resources
in form of capabilities critical to
resource recombination. So, sensing,
sense making and duality management.
Cool. I find it interesting here that
one, two and three are within the
lifecycle of an organization or an
organism. They refer to the reliability
of action, the ability to have an
appropriately expanded vocabulary in
terms of sophistication to describe
relevant action. And then three,
essentially attention, which is to make
sure that you're not just falling victim
to hyper skewed or hypernormal stimuli,
but rather you're using your attention
to enrich incoming stimuli and
also not ignoring what you're not
totally paying attention to. That might
be on the margins of relevance. But then
four is framed here as an anticipatory
question in the long run whether
the capabilities are successful to
manage resource recombination. That's
the question of life and death. So one,
two and three are like the behavioral
imperatives and then four is kind of
like the organism looking to the
horizon. Maybe it makes it or maybe its
offspring does, or maybe none of the
above.
Thank you. And then just this
final quote from the
paper or from the book. He says,
duality is an essential quantum concept
that underpins the mastery of managing
the distributed and discontinuous nature
of today's market realities.
And I'm curious as to what Bijan is
referring to as duality. Like in the
quantum context. I always think about
wave particle duality, but I think he
has talked here a lot about
superposition. And maybe he's referring
to superposition, maybe he means super
cognition. Like you can exist in two
different states until for a long time.
Like you can be both black and white,
one and zero. So I'm not really sure
what he's referring to as duality, but I
think maybe we'll get into it in the
next.
Yeah, I was curious whether the
connection he's making here is like one
of analogy saying like hey, the same way
you don't know what was out there in the
quantum world, you observe something and
you kind of collapse all of these waves
into electron. Is it an analogy in
the active inference free energy
governance world with through the
inactivist approach? Or is he saying
that this is actually like the same
thing, that is the same principle
underlying and I wasn't totally sure
which way what way he meant there.
Yes, we should explore there's the wave
particle duality famous there's the
observer observed duality or the
experimenter environment? Duality.
There's multiple dualities. And then if
we think back to Bayesian physics,
what does this help us with?
Let's go into it more in the next
chapter and then see how it actually
connects back. Otherwise, I believe it
puts us squarely into the quantum
business advice genre.
But I know there's more to it. And that
would be, like, a very sellable quantum
business advice. Quantum Business
strategy manager. That's my new job.
I'd be, like, a heck of a consultant
title. Am I working? Am I not working?
You could check. You still might not
find out. Am I
here? Am I there? Where am I? Actually,
you can't measure my position and my
momentum at the same time. That's pretty
funny. Okay. All right. I think
we've reached the end of our set of
slides. Looking forward to exploring the
quantum in more detail as I find the
quantum concepts fascinating. I guess
Bijan also does. Do you guys have
anything else to add before we say
goodbye? That's it?
No? Okay. Thanks, Tyler.
Next week. Thanks, Joe. Very well.